As we sink deeper into the fever tree,
that is this unusually divisive and fear
filled season,
it's nice to have an anecdotal feeling
in the form of winter holidays
throughout which despite being co opted
by,
hallmark commercialism,
a sense of family and of coming together
predominates.
My favorite ritual of this time of year
is the annual broadcast,
a frank capra's.
It's a wonderful life.
On Christmas Eve,
what was once a postwar box office flop
has become a cultural phenomenon
recognized as one of the great cinematic
masterpieces by one of our very best
directors watching it.
Of course,
it's tempting to brush off this film is
overly sentimental and nostalgic,
which it is,
but I think we judge it like this at our
own peril indeed,
with it's a wonderful life.
Capra interrogate some of the key
contradictions at the heart of American
life to see whether or not they can be
reconciled or if in fact they don't
exist at all.
Contradictions between the individual
and the community,
between adventure and domesticity and
between success and an ordinary life.
He stages these contradictions in the
figure of George Bailey,
the citizen of the small town of Bedford
falls and the president of the local
building and loan is the film begins.
We don't know exactly what has happened
to George,
only that he's in serious trouble and
has reached the end of his rope and that
he's about to be $80 by divine
intervention in the form of a guardian
angel seeking to earn his wings.
We learned about George's life as his
angel does in a series of flashbacks.
Man wants to know something about him,
though
George we learn has big dreams of
leaving Bedford falls,
traveling the world and becoming a
metropolitan archetypes,
shaking the dust of this crummy little
town off my feet and I'm going to see
the oral,
but his selflessness,
his drive to do the right thing
repeatedly comes in the way of these
streams and you also learn about Bedford
falls,
a close knit community of mostly good
people leading simple lives,
which is under the constant threat of
being taken over by a ruthless
businessman called Mr Potter.
The only thing standing in potters way,
his George Bailey,
his father,
and they're empathetic building and loan
operation,
the foil to potter,
the clear representation of corruption
and evil,
and the film is not George himself,
but Mary Hatch,
George's eventual wife,
a compassionate young woman who is quite
happy to stay and live in Bedford falls.
It's important to note that both Potter
and Mary show up in every flashback
representing George's desires for fame
and fortune on the one hand and his
drive to do the right thing for his
community.
On the other,
of course,
it's Mary's side that eventually wins
out,
but for the large majority of the film,
George is not rewarded for doing the
right thing.
He's punished when young George rescues
his brother from a freezing lake.
He loses the hearing in his left ear
when you weren't his boss about a
potentially disastrous accident.
He gets beaten when his father dies and
he takes on his responsibilities at the
building and loan.
He loses his chance for travel and
college when there's a run on the bank,
he misses his own honeymoon.
Every noble sacrifice for Bedford falls
makes Bedford falls feel more like a
trap,
and instead of bringing him closer to
the community,
he's helping capra shows him,
isolated from it in this shot,
after realizing that his dreams of
travel are finally squashed for good,
George stands isolated against a train
that he'll never get on before he walked
slowly back into the crowd,
putting a smile on again like he always
does.
Despite this parade of personal wounds,
George's able to remain resilient until
the very end when his scatterbrained
uncle misplaces $8,000
and puts them in danger of going to jail
for fraud,
things get worse and worse,
and George believing himself worth more
dead than alive.
Contemplate suicide.
It's at this point that his guardian
Angel Clarence intervenes clearance odd
body angel,
second class shows George what Bedford
falls would have been like had he never
existed.
What George sees is a nightmare.
Bedford falls is now Pottersville and
all the dreams he had have an exciting
life of adventure and exoticism have
returned as perverted versions of
themselves on the main drag of his
former home.
The moon,
that George Promise to Lasso for Mary
that she had made into a lovely
needlepoint picture is made ugly and
sleazy in the form of the blue moon cafe
Martinis Bar,
a place where any break from decent
behavior was not tolerated.
As become a garish speakeasy where
anything goes,
everything is turned into an opportunity
for crass commercialism,
even Georgia's home has become a
boarding house.
When George finally gets his old life
back,
he's rewarded with generosity from the
community who bail him out in an
unbelievably touching finale that ends
with everyone,
including the cops who came to arrest
him singing all plant science.
It's easy to get carried away in this
wave of feeling,
but it's important to remember what
hasn't changed,
and that's basically everything.
George Bailey still has to live in his
drafty,
old house scraping by to support his
family.
His business,
despite being bailed out by the town,
remains at the brink of being swallowed
by potters,
relentless expansion and the pot our
faces.
No consequences at all despite being the
main protagonist.
Despite stealing money from George
Bailey,
he's not vanquished.
He's up $8,000
in some sense.
CAPRA reconciles the contradictions I
mentioned before,
success is not mutually exclusive to an
ordinary life adventure can be found in
a domestic setting and yet the most
basic contradiction that between the
individual and the community is left
open ended.
America has struggled with this
contradiction since before its founding.
How does a culture predicated on
individualism maintain public virtue?
How does an economic system that
incentivizes individual success keep
from exploiting communities?
If you have the answer,
tell us because we're still at the eve
of 2016 struggling to figure it out.
I feel George's dilemma,
as I'm sure many of you do,
the world shines with the promise of
adventure and possibility.
All that could be gained.
Experience learned.
If only you were to commit yourself to a
radical individualism and yet the
responsibilities of family and of the
Community Nag.
They call us back.
They ask us to sacrifice and solution to
this.
Everyone finds their own balance,
but you should keep in mind that it's
these personal dilemmas played out in
society at large that ultimately draw
the fault lines in our politics and
frank capra and George Bailey's time
following World War II,
the idea of an American destiny of the
American way still had weight and
consensus.
A string of disasters have weakened.
Our resolve in such a thing have
fractured our ability to imagine a
consensus and into the void rushes the
heirs to Henry Potter.
This is why the message of it's a
wonderful life.
A message of hope and perspective is not
so shallow as it seems.
The contradictions in the film are never
quite resolved.
Something beautifully dramatized by the
finial on Georgia stairs.
There will always be an incompleteness
to life,
but hope is not naive.
It's hardiness and resolve against a
situation that cannot give us assurances
or guarantees.
The film shows us that a change of heart
and perspective far from being
powerless,
nostalgia and the face of an unusually
divisive and fear filled season can be a
genuinely revolutionary.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching and happy holidays.
Whatever you celebrate out there,
if you want to help me make more of
these nerdwriter videos,
if you like what I'm doing here and you
want to see more,
I'd ask you to pledge a little bit of
money to my patrion page.
Everything helps.
You guys have been so generous so far
and you know,
all the money that you pledge goes
directly into improving this channel.
Um,
you know,
these take a lot of time and essentially
money to make.
So everything you do is much,
much,
much appreciated.
This is one of my favorite movies of all
time.
Jimmy Stewart is my favorite actor of
all time.
Someone once said that George Bailey was
like a vessel that Jimmy Stewart poured
every nuance of as being into an.
I totally agree with that.
I love this movie.
I'll never get tired of it.
I watch it every year.
Thank you again for watching and I will
see you guys next Wednesday.